[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: Hi, everybody,
and welcome to Talks
at Google Cambridge.
Today I'm delighted to introduce
Professor Sunstein, who
will be talking about
his newest book,
"The World According
to Star Wars."
Professor Sunstein is the Robert
Walmsley University Professor
at Harvard and the
founder and director
of the university's program
on behavioral economics
and public policy.
He's written many,
many books, including
best seller "Nudge," "Simpler,
the Future of Government,"
and "Republic.com," and,
of course, his newest book,
"The World According
to Star Wars."
He's a pretty big fan of
"Star Wars," as are probably
many of you in this
room, so please join me
in welcoming up
Professor Sunstein.
[APPLAUSE]
CASS R. SUNSTEIN:
Thank you so much.
It's a complete
thrill to be here.
I think "Star Wars"
the universe presaged
a lot of the work going
on at Google, didn't it?
So this is extremely fitting.
There's "Star Wars."
Brings a burst of
excitement and nostalgia
and hope for what's coming next.
There's a book.
There's the origins of
this unlikely project.
I'm a law professor.
I work some on social science
and psychology and economics.
That's my son.
He was taken with "Star
Wars" at the age of five,
and his, to me, surprising
fascination with "Star Wars"
hooked me.
My puzzle and topic
here is very simple.
Why did "Star Wars" succeed?
For those who like
"Star Wars," that's
not an interesting question.
I'm hoping that for
those four people
on the planet who don't
like "Star Wars," that's
not uninteresting either.
Because it has
general implications
for why ideas
succeed and fail, why
certain understandings
of rights get out there,
why some products end up
being terrifically successful
and others don't, why
some politicians--
is it likely that someone
named Barack Hussein
Obama would become president
of the United States?
I don't think that
was anticipated.
It happened.
Was it likely that
Donald Trump would
be the Republican nominee?
That wasn't anticipated.
It looks like it's
going to happen.
Why are rebellions
both so hard to predict
and often so massively
successful, like the Arab
Spring?
"Star Wars" success has
some similar features
I'm going to try to suggest.
Here's the epigraph
for these remarks.
It's a dialogue between
two titans, George Lucas,
the mastermind of "Star
Wars," and Lawrence Kasdan,
his co-author.
Kasdan, a genius,
as Lucas is, sharply
disagreed, the two of
them, on the question
whether Luke or
somebody else should
die in "Return of the Jedi."
And Kasdan said,
Luke should die.
And Lucas said, Luke's
not going to die.
And then Kasdan said, well,
someone else important
should die.
And Lucas said, someone else
important is not going to die.
You're a product of the '80s.
This is not that kind of movie.
And Kasdan then said,
with evident feeling,
I'm saying the movie has
more emotional weight
if someone you love
is lost along the way.
The journey has more impact.
That was a very
feeling-full statement
on the part of Kasdan.
And Lucas responded,
apparently, very quickly, I
don't like that, and
I don't believe that.
I think those are precious
words because of their immediacy
and clarity.
They're also behavioral
words in the sense
that they track understanding
from behavioral science, which
is that often our
beliefs are motivated.
I don't like that, and
I don't believe that.
That's Lucas' sequence.
OK.
So as of now, the
"Star Wars" movies
have made more than $30 billion.
That's more than the gross
domestic product of about 90
of the world's nations.
If "Star Wars" were
a nation, it would
rank about the middle of the
193 nations on the planet.
Doesn't it deserve its own
place at the United Nations?
It has become the
defining saga of our time.
President Obama ended a news
conference in December saying,
I've got to go see "Star Wars."
Secretary Clinton ended a
Democratic debate saying,
may the force be with you.
And Senator Cruz tweeted before
one of the Republican debates
something that picked up
on "The Force Awakens."
so it's bipartisan
and all-American.
Ironically and stunningly, no
one expected it to be a hit.
Nobody, really.
Throughout its production at
Fox studios, there was apathy.
They hoped a lot of times
it would just go away.
The movie theaters,
whose business
it is to predict success,
gave advance guarantees
of $1.5 million.
That's pathetic.
Fox's hope was $10 million.
That's a low bar.
They couldn't get
close to the low bar.
Fox didn't even print
enough celluloid to meet
the early demand.
They literally didn't think the
movie was worth the celluloid
on which it was printed.
Right after "A New
Hope," originally
called "Star Wars" opened,
George Lucas and spouse
went on vacation in Hawaii.
It was not just because
they needed a break.
It's because they thought
they'd probably released a flop.
In Hawaii, they could
escape what Lucas thought
might well be a disaster.
The actors didn't have
much faith in it, either.
Harrison Ford says there's
this giant guy walking around
in a dog suit.
It was ridiculous.
OK.
So we could think that
the success of "Star Wars"
had something to
do with the timing,
and this may have broad lessons
about products and politicians
and ideas that you have to hit
the culture in the right way
at the right time.
That's an external explanation.
Or you could have an internal
explanation, something
about the amazingness of the
thing whose success we're
trying to explain.
I'm going to go very
briskly over a series
of possible explanations.
And the external
explanations are
going to look very bad, to give
a little bit of the game away.
There was a movie a few
years ago that won the Oscar.
It's called "Searching
for Sugar Man,"
and it's about a rock singer
from the early 1970s named
Rodriguez, about whom even
connoisseurs of rock music
knew nothing because he released
two albums, as they were
then called, and they failed.
So think of this as one of a
zillion wanna-be rock stars who
flopped and ended
up, in this case,
going into the construction
business as a demolition man.
Unbeknownst to himself,
Rodriguez was, in South Africa,
a giant.
They would speak of him with
awe and reverence, Rodriguez.
They wondered what
had happened to him.
Had he burned himself
on stage, as rumors
had it, and thus
become an iconic kind
of self-immolating guy?
Now, there's a puzzle.
Why did Rodriguez become
a runaway success--
bigger than the Beatles,
really-- in South Africa
and kind of an utter failure
in the United States?
What's going on there?
Well, I think we have
a little bit of clue
from "Harry Potter,"
where 12 publishers turned
down the "Harry Potter" novels.
J.K. Rowling had a
struggle getting published.
The publishers are
supposed to know
about quality and saleability.
The advance originally for
"Harry Potter" was very small.
What happened there?
OK.
There's a strange tale
involving a mystery
writer named Robert Gottlieb.
I'm not sure if
you've heard of him.
He's written three
novels, the first of which
was called "The
Cuckoo's Calling."
"The Cuckoo's Calling"
was very well reviewed.
Sold horribly.
So it was one of these
critical successes
that was disappearing.
But it emerged, I
think, by happenstance
that the real author of
"The Cuckoo's Calling"
is J.K. Rowling, and
the book exploded.
Bestsellers.
What's going on there?
William Blake, one of
the most revered poets
in the English language,
disappeared from the canon
for a long time.
Jane Austen herself
was-- and I'm
trying to see if you're
paying attention,
because it's misspelled
there-- Jane Austen
was one of several
novelists in her era,
and she was not
thought to be the best.
Why did Jane Austen
and William Blake
turn out to be canonical
where people who at the time
were thought to be better
have, in fact, dropped out?
OK.
Here's a clue.
This is an experiment a few
years ago, online experiment,
where-- it's called
the music lab,
where there's a
real website which
has dozens of songs on it.
In the control condition,
you can go on the website
and download the songs you like.
That's the control.
And that measure gives
an independent measure
of popularity.
In eight subgroups,
something different happened,
which is you could see in
your randomly sorted group--
the group into which you've
been randomly placed--
you can see how many people had
downloaded all of the songs.
So there's a control
condition, where
you don't see the
social influences,
you don't see what's
happened to other people,
and there are eight
other groups, where
you can see how
the songs are doing
with the relevant population
of 1,000 visitors, thousands
of visitors.
OK.
If intrinsic quality
is what mattered,
you'd predict that
the eight worlds where
you saw the initial
downloads would turn out
to be the same as the
control condition.
Yes, quality [? would ?]
[? out. ?] And that's a very
plausible hypothesis.
That's not what happened.
Basically, while the best
songs never completely tanked
and the worst songs were
never spectacular successes,
otherwise, anything
could happen.
A song which did very
poorly in one world
could do very well in another,
where the only difference was
that it got initial downloads.
A song that did very
well in most worlds
could tank in others,
and the reason
is it didn't get a lot
of initial downloads.
Now, this is a profound
explanation, I think,
of success and failure
in terms of movies,
products of all kinds,
books, political candidates,
and ideas.
The question is, is there an
initial burst of enthusiasm
which zillions of
other people see?
When that happens, something
whose intrinsic quality
isn't higher than
that of other things
can be culturally very resonant.
Not because of the
culture, but because
of the relative happenstance
that a number of people
got excited about it early.
OK.
In terms of theory, what
we're speaking about here
is cascades.
There are two kinds of cascades.
One is informational and
the other is reputational.
An informational
cascade is when you're
in a kind of temporal queue.
You're deciding among
five products, let's say.
The first person in
the queue decides
on product B of the five.
The second person in the
queue isn't quite sure,
kind of likes product C, but
is moved by the first person
to get product B, too.
Once the first two people
have gotten product B,
then the third person
is going to have
to have a lot of
information to choose
one of the other products
because two people have ended
up choosing product B. I think
with respect to a large number
of social success stories,
including Rodriguez in South
Africa and Rodriguez
in the United States,
the deal maker or
the deal breaker
is whether you benefit from
an informational cascade.
For many things,
including "Star Wars,"
there are reputational
cascades as well.
If you didn't know, at certain
period in 1977, anything
about "Star Wars," and you
were, say, 17 years old,
you are a loser.
You had to know
about "Star Wars."
You would risk your reputation
among your peers if you didn't.
And if you had seen
it and didn't like it,
you'd also risk your reputation.
So you had to A, see
it, and B, like it.
If you didn't like
it, you had to it
in the sense of
saying you liked it.
And that put
reputational pressure
on members of the population.
Some things, and I hope
this is very familiar here,
benefit from network effects.
That people enjoy them because
other people enjoy them,
that's a kind of a
loose generalization
of the idea of network effects.
And for "The Force
Awakens," a lot of people
went because they thought
everyone was going.
OK.
Is that true for "Star Wars"?
Is that the full account?
Really?
Seriously?
Is "Star Wars" like
one of those kind
of average songs
in the music lab
experiment that exploded
because early people liked it?
I mean really and
seriously to be
doubting the fullness of the
explanation I've just given.
Think, if you would, about
the Arab Spring and the fall
of communism.
Surely the timing of
both of those events,
highly unpredictable,
had a lot to do
with what we're now discussing.
And there's terrific
empirical work
suggesting that informational
cascades and reputational
cascades were crucial
to when those happened.
But the fall of
authoritarian governance
isn't just a product
of cascade effects.
They're also
authoritarian governments,
and what is sought to
replace them by the rebels
is something that has higher
intrinsic quality, which
is to suggest that to attribute
the success of "Star Wars"
solely to the explanation just
given is probably a mistake.
OK.
Second idea.
What "Star Wars" benefited from
is the appeal of the monomyth.
So there's a guy named
Joseph Campbell, discovered,
by the way, by Jacqueline
Kennedy, President Kennedy's
wife, as an editor.
Joseph Campbell said that there
is a monomyth in cultures where
there's a hero's
journey-- Jesus, Buddha,
Mohammad, and many
others show all
or many features
of the monomyth--
where people receive at
a young age a challenge.
They decline it.
They find a mentor.
They leave home.
They're tested.
They face dangers.
They get help.
They reunite in some sense
with home, and they celebrate.
Now, that has universal appeal.
It's all of us.
Every human being's
journey is, in a way,
the hero's journey,
which helps account
for its spectacular
appeal in any country,
basically, that you can name.
Spiderman.
Hero's journey.
Jessica Jones, the
best heroic journey
in the last decade in my view.
If you haven't seen it,
watch "Jessica Jones."
She is replicating the
monomyth in a distinctive way.
And Luke Skywalker,
no doubt about it.
But there are a lot of monomyths
out there, and most of them
tanked.
You haven't even heard of them.
So it can't be sufficient
for "Star Wars"
success, though it's true
that it tracked the monomyth.
OK.
Third explanation.
"Star Wars" has many
possible meanings.
You can easily see it as an
essentially Christian tale
in which Anakin Skywalker
is a Christ-like figure who
dies, in a way, for our sins,
finds salvation, and guarantees
something like that to us
in a tale that in many ways
mimics the New Testament.
You can see Luke's
journey in the same way.
So the Christian
resonance in the tale
helps give it a kind
of cultural appeal.
You can see it as Freudian.
No question about that.
Anakin is in love with
his mother, who dies.
He falls for, in a
literal way, a woman who's
much older who
says Anakin, you'll
always be a little boy to me.
Kind of Freudian.
Both Luke and Anakin have
big-time father issues, and OK.
You can see it as a
Jeffersonian tale that
would resonate in the United
States about rebellion
and the need for a kind of
monitoring of potentially
authoritarian governance.
There are crazy theories about
Jar Jar Binks being a Sith Lord
or about Han Solo having
the force or about
the wonderfulness of the Empire.
These are crazy theories,
but they're ingenious,
and they can fit the tale.
Does that have
explanatory power?
Some.
But here's a pedantic word
on necessary and sufficient
conditions.
If you want to explain
"Star Wars" success,
we have to distinguish
between two.
It may be a necessary condition
that it have multiple meanings.
Maybe that makes it intriguing.
But it's not a
sufficient condition.
There are a lot of
terrible things out there
that have many meanings
that don't make $30 billion
and probably what's being done
by the people who are focusing
on many meanings as
the source of success
is that they're committing
a statistical error called
sampling on the
dependent variable.
That is, they take
a variable that
is connected with a bunch of
successful things, of which
"Star Wars" is one,
and then claiming
that that's causally
responsible for its success.
But it turned out--
if it turned out
that the five culturally
most resonant things, let's
say, in the last 50 years
were all made by someone who
was born in December
or who had the letter
L in their last name, that would
not be causally responsible.
And I think this is
suffering from that blunder.
OK.
Explanation number four.
What a lot of people
all over the world,
and certainly in the
United States, like
is tales of republics
and empires.
The theory in the
saga, and its presaged
in the beloved original trilogy,
it's very clearly spelled out
in the underrated
prequels, is that democracy
falls to thunderous applause.
And the idea is that republics
are vulnerable and fragile
and that they fall in a kind
of predictable, somewhat
stylized way.
The fall of Rome, the fall of
Germany, Stalin's authority,
all had something
to do with a theme
that "Star Wars"
is very alert to.
This does resonate,
and I think it
is accounting for the beginnings
of what we're seeing now,
which is a rebirth of
interest in the prequels
because they are saying
something that connects
at least with
developments in Europe
and possibly the United States.
What I'm going to say
about that explanation
is it captures some of
the appeal of "Star Wars,"
but again, it's neither--
it's certainly not
sufficient for cultural success.
You can tell a lot
of boring tales
about republics
falling to empires,
and it's not necessary.
OK.
Here's a more interesting
explanation, I think.
The zeitgeist.
The culture.
And here the idea is that
after the assassination
of the Kennedys, Martin
Luther King, and Malcolm
X, and the tulmult
of the Vietnam era,
and malaise, which was
Jimmy Carter's term for what
the country was in, the time was
kind of perfect for a new hope.
That's what the country wanted.
A new hope.
A lift was needed,
and George Lucas
delivered in on a
silver spaceship.
That's exactly what happened.
And many of the sociologically
most attuned critics
of the question
I'm exploring now
put their finger on this one,
and they say this is the one.
I'm going to be very hard on
this explanation in a way that
bears on "Star Wars" but
also on political success
and cultural success, Taylor
Swift and "Harry Potter."
I'm going to suggest that all
of these things that succeed,
this is a tempting but very
problematic explanation.
The reason is it's always
possible to generate an ex post
zeitgeit explanation.
It's child's play to say the
most popular thing X succeeded
because of cultural
factors A, B, and C. You
can say "Harry Potter"
after 9/11, of course.
Taylor Swift after the
recession, of course.
But is that true?
Here's a way to think about it.
Imagine that "Star
Wars" did great
in the 1990s, the early
aughts, tomorrow, or the 1930s.
We could easily generate
a cultural account
of why that happened,
and it would
be as plausible as the
ones that are out there.
1930s, depression.
They needed a new hope.
1990s, Clinton.
1980s, conventionality.
Luke Skywalker, perfect for
the earnestness of the times.
Plausible?
Yes.
True?
No.
A fairy tale?
Yes.
OK.
Here's explanation six.
"Star Wars" engages
intriguingly with the light side
and the dark side.
William Blake, the
great English poet,
wrote of the greatest religious
text in the English language.
The reason John Milton,
who wrote "Paradise Lost,"
wrote in fetters when he
wrote of angels and God
and at liberty when
of devils and hell
is because he was a true
poet and of the devil's party
without knowing it.
That's a mouthful, and
it does account for some
of the appeal of "Star Wars."
Notice, if you
would, Blake, it's
not clear if he
actually believed this,
but he's venturing the idea that
a true poet is of the devil's
party without knowing it.
Blake also wrote in
one of his proverbs
those who restrain their
desires do so because theirs is
weak enough to be restrained.
A brilliant essay on "Star
Wars" by Lydia Millet
says that Vader is the most
erotic figure in the "Star
Wars" family, and
the only tragic one,
and because of this, he
had a terrible beauty.
He had an erotic charge
because he gets what he wants.
He makes the dark
side seem sexy.
That's her explanation.
Is that relevant?
Oh, yeah.
No question that's relevant.
But remember the pedantic words
about necessary and sufficient
conditions.
That's a caution.
OK.
Now we're going to get to
my preferred explanations.
There's a son, Luke.
Anakin saves his son.
Told repeatedly
by Yoda that fear
is the path to the dark side
and you must be detached
and not fear loss,
Anakin is attached.
Luke saves his father
because of attachment.
Anakin, in the most
moving scene to date
of "Star Wars," and
he's called Anakin
in the script for the first
time, says to Luke's plea,
I must save you, father, Anakin
responds, you already have.
"Star Wars" is all
about fathers and sons.
It can be generalized to
mothers and daughters.
But the original six, they're
all about fathers and sons.
And that appeal accounts for the
kind of depth of the attachment
that "Star Wars" itself
produces in many of its viewers.
Since my book came
out, I can't tell you
how often children--
mostly boys,
but some girls--
who are grown now
have come up to me
misty-eyed and talked
about what "Star
Wars" meant to them.
And even more, I can't tell you
how often dads, often 60s, 70s,
and 80s, have come
up to me and said,
I saw this with
my boy when young.
And that is a big part of
the power of the movies.
But it would be possible to
say that the father-son thing
wouldn't work unless there
was a kind of dark mirror
in the saga which tells us a
lot about agency and freedom.
George Lucas, mirroring
the tale of Luke
in "Return of the
Jedi," with Anakin
in "Revenge of the Sith,"
said-- this is Lucas-- Anakin
says yes to the dark side.
Luke says no.
And it's under very precisely
identical situations.
There's a pervasive
disagreement in the saga.
It has everything
to do with freedom.
It makes these all-American
movies, I think.
The emperor thinks that life's
trajectory is foreordained.
Everything is happening
as I have foreseen.
Yoda thinks differently.
Always in motion is the future.
Guess who's right?
OK.
So here's what Star
Wars is really about.
By their innocence and
goodness and by the power
of their faith and hope,
children redeem their parents.
As every child wishes
and hopes, any parent
is likely to save the
child-- risk his life
to save his child's,
even if it means
a contest with the
emperor himself.
And when he does,
the Force is going
to be right there with him.
Lawrence Kasdan, very recently
describing his movie career,
said it's the biggest
adventure you can have,
making up your own life,
and it's true for everybody.
It's infinite possibility.
It's like I don't
know what I'm going
to do in the next
few minutes, but I
feel I can get through it.
It's an assertion
of a life force.
"Star Wars" is primal,
and it is a fairy tale,
but it's not just
a retelling of what
Joseph Campbell had to say.
It's real topic is the fork
in the road and the decision
you make on the spot.
It's universality
comes from its focus
on the most essential feature
of the human condition,
freedom of choice
amidst a clouded future.
At the decisive moment, grown
children announce their choice.
I am a Jedi like my
father before me.
So sure, it resonated
with the time.
No question it benefited from
cascade and network effects.
But it was bound to succeed.
It's too good.
I like that, and I believe it.
Thanks.
The floor is open.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] your
own cultural artifacts,
what lessons do you take
from this of this crafting
and promotion [INAUDIBLE]?
CASS R. SUNSTEIN: Oh.
So in promoting my own
products, most of which
do not get large
numbers of Americans
opening their wallet for them, I
kind of learned from the book--
from doing the book that kind of
early enthusiasm is important.
But my own experience of
writing and especially
this book is doing
the book was kind
of more fun than I've ever had.
And I thought really,
I wanted to write
a book that would be fun for
me, and I hoped for readers.
And the marketing stuff I've
basically left to others.
But my advice to
anyone would be be
like those successful products
in the music download study.
That is, make sure that
there's a kind of echo chamber
of enthusiasm that is getting
louder and louder because
of the nature and numbers
of the early adopters.
That's what I would advise.
And if you look at the
successful movies or TV shows
or books, it's not clear that
they're a lot better than ones
that you've never heard of.
They're usually good, but
the reason they get there
is what we're now talking about.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I noticed that
most of your examples
that you proceeded
to somewhat tear down
about why "Star Wars"
succeeded connected both
the original trilogy
and the prequels,
as you noted these
partway through.
And I'm curious how-- what
the analysis is like when
you try to separate them.
A lot of the cases
where it seemed like it
was a lot stronger if
you include the prequels.
Well, as far as I
know, "Star Wars"
was pretty big before
the prequels, too.
And at that, if you think
about just the original movie
versus the others, though
that was a little bit
before my time.
So yes, I was wondering
what your thoughts
of the differences there are.
CASS R. SUNSTEIN:
It's a great point.
It's a great-- you're
completely right.
So to say that "Star
Wars" succeeded
in a way that takes on all
six, that's probably a mistake.
The one we want to
put a spotlight on
is "A New Hope," episode
four, and probably
episodes five and six.
Not the first three.
The explanations I gave,
rifling through in my mind,
they all are plausible
for the original ones,
which are the ones to explain.
The one that's hardest
to apply to those
is the Empire Republic
tale, which is there
in the original trilogy.
But to say that's why it
succeeded, that's crazy.
It's there, but it's
not the main theme.
So that puts another nail in
the coffin of that explanation.
But the dark side,
light side explanation,
the ones about cascade effects,
the idea of the hero's journey,
that and all the
others, I think,
work for the first three.
Now, you could say, in the
spirit of your question,
that the success of the
prequels, the economic success,
they made a ton of money,
was essentially foreordained
because you had a built-in
audience of enthusiasts.
And that's probably correct.
And you could say the success
of "The Empire Strikes
Back" and "The Return of the
Jedi," that was pretty much
guaranteed, because "A New
Hope," as it's now called,
was the second most
successful movie-- wasn't, is
the second most successful
movie economically of all time.
The only one that beats it
is "Gone With the Wind."
and I like to think, you know,
frankly, I don't give a damn,
because "Gone With the Wind"
was a very different era when
everyone was going to
the movies and also
has had decades more time.
So plausibly, "A New Hope" is
the biggest success of all,
and it paved the way
towards the others.
And all of the explanations
would have to be applied to it.
So the explanation on which
I'm converging, really,
is that it was
fantastic, and there's
a puzzle about why
no one saw that
except Stephen Spielberg
and a couple others,
but that it probably needed
the cascade and network
effects early so that it became
like Rodriguez in South Africa.
By the way, my
explanation of Rodriguez
in South Africa and
the United States
is 100% the music
lab experiment.
He's really good, Rodriguez.
But he didn't make it
in the United States
because he didn't get
the early downloads.
He could've been
someone everyone
would have heard of
in the United States.
He was good enough.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you very much.
One of the reasons I
really got into "Star Wars"
is this rich imaginary world.
And I was surprised not to
see it as one of the reasons,
because I feel like kids
everywhere sort of make up
these stories.
And I wonder if you have
any thoughts around that.
CASS R. SUNSTEIN: Oh,
that's a great point.
So that would be a strong
candidate for an explanation.
And what I'm puzzling
over is it does
have-- it is a whole
world, not just a galaxy.
You can enter it
and puzzle over it
and imagine pasts and futures.
That's one of its
fantastic features.
Now, there are a number of
movies and television shows
that try to be whole worlds
and, in a way, succeed
but aren't that interesting,
and so they don't go anywhere.
So this is both a whole
world and-- and then you
have to say some things probably
along the lines just described.
But you raise a great point.
"Star Trek," by the way-- I'm
also a fan of "Star Trek,"--
has a similar feature.
"Harry Potter," too.
And there's another science--
"Battlestar Galactica,"
a great TV show.
The second one, not the
first, has that feature also.
But there are other
successful things
that don't have the
whole world character.
They're smaller.
And I'm thinking science fiction
by it's nature, or fantasy.
Tolkien.
It's kind a whole world stuff.
And so that would
suggest that that
might be a necessary
condition for success,
but not sufficient.
AUDIENCE: I have a
couple of things to say.
First of all, one of the
first surprises in "Star Wars"
is the fact that it
started with episode four,
and you're-- you're confronted
with that on the very first
screen.
So I'm wondering, certainly,
as I recall, I mean,
as the series went along, the
very fact that it was part
of this ongoing saga and
that there were more episodes
to come and more that
had already happened
was probably a very intriguing
factor that probably
contributed to people's
continuing interest in it
over the years.
But the other thing
I wanted to say
was about the
whole father theme,
which, as I recall, by
the way, didn't really
surface in the first movie,
at least not very much.
It took a couple before
that really got going.
But it reminds me very much
of another series, which
is one of my favorite
operas, "Die Walkure."
And the final scene
in "Die Walkure" to me
is one of the most powerful
emotional moments in all
of opera, where Wotan carries
his daughter Brunnhilde up,
he puts her to sleep and carries
her up and puts her inside
a ring of fire which can
only be broken, ultimately,
by Siegfried.
But the whole reason
that this has happened
is that Brunnhilde
has disobeyed him,
but what makes it
really powerful,
aside from just the
father-daughter thing-- I have
a daughter and
it's always really
hit me very directly-- is that,
yes, Brunnhilde disobeyed him,
but on one level, Wotan
encouraged her to disobey him
and had his own rebellious side
which he really on some level
wanted Brunnhilde to carry out.
So this is very
complicated thing going on,
disobedience and
rebellion, but tied up
with the god actually being
conflicted about this as well.
So I think that opera ties in
these themes that you mentioned
of the father-offspring
theme and the rebellion
versus obedience theme,
in a very direct way
and certainly, to me, a
much greater and deeper way
than "Star Wars" does.
But you know, it goes back
to the whole Joseph Campbell
thing, and you know,
I was just wondering
if you had thought more
about other examples of this
throughout some of the
great artistic works.
CASS R. SUNSTEIN: OK.
That's great.
So the only thing that I
stumbled over in what you said
was greater and deeper
than "Star Wars."
That really upset me, and I'm
going to try to overcome that,
because I like you
very much otherwise.
You're right that the
mother-child, father-child
tensions are in cultures
of many kinds and things
that are iconic for us.
King Lear is an evident example.
Hamlet, in its own way,
is another example.
So it goes very deep.
I think I'll make a
little plea for one
point you made, and then a
little plea for "Star Wars."
So in "A New Hope," my view,
which I have researched
with baffling intensity given
it's not that important--
my view is that
George Lucas didn't
know that Darth
Vader was going to be
the father until
after "A New Hope,"
and it was a ingenious
burst of creativity.
He has said on
multiple occasions
that the story was about
a father and twins,
but the early drafts are
highly suggestive that that was
a late innovation on his part.
So father stuff becomes deep
in "The Empire Strikes Back."
Who's the dad is a nice
mystery in "A New Hope."
Luke doesn't know
who his father is.
That's intriguing.
But you're right,
that's not kind
of in the heart of the thing.
I think that-- this may be
Kool-Aid drinking on my part,
but I think "A New Hope" becomes
culturally and artistically
really major in that I
am your father moment.
Because the I am your father
moment has a characteristic,
and it's hard to think of
something that is similar,
of instant incredulity on
the part of viewers, followed
by an immediate, of course.
That's very hard
to pull off, where
it's stunningly surprising, but
also like a key that completely
fits the lock.
And I think law is
often like that.
And my guess is that creativity
in engineering and music
and literature is also often
like that, where you have
a burst of thinking that
sorts everything out,
often in the direction of
greater simplification,
but two hours before,
you would have
thought that can't be possible.
And the idea that
same-sex marriage
is constitutionally
required by all states
now, that's an I am your
father moment, where
at a certain
relatively recent point
that we've seen a quite
implausible rendering
of the narrative of our
constitutional tradition.
Now it seems like an I am
your father moment in the best
possible sense.
I'll tell you one thing that
is like this a little bit,
and it's maybe not as
familiar as I wish it were,
which is, as by its great
novel, "Possession," which
has-- I won't give
away the surprise,
but it has something
about parents
and familial connections
that is, I think,
it's this the greatest novel of
the last, I'll say, 50 years.
And it has something along the
lines of what you were saying.
It has more than one.
I say no more.
And while it's not as vivid and
arresting as "Star Wars," it
breaks my heart to say
so, it may be better.
AUDIENCE: I had a
more general question.
As more people get access
to internet and technology
to make network effects
it'll only compound them,
but as things like
instant gratification
and people's preferences
change, do you
see these principles holding
true over time in 20, 30 years
and continue to be
predictable in the field
of behavioral
economics, or do you
see them changing drastically?
CASS R. SUNSTEIN: OK.
So let's make--
thank you for that.
Let's make a few distinctions
that might be useful.
So behavioral
economics, I think,
is most usefully
understood as focusing
on how human beings depart
from economic understanding
as a rationality.
So the fact that in New York
relatively recently, people
were really scared of getting
Ebola, even though at that time
more Americans had
married Kardashians
than had died of
Ebola, and people
weren't going around saying,
I might marry a Kardashian,
either with terror or hope.
But the event of getting Ebola
was so available in the head
that probability
judgements went awry,
so people assess
probabilities often
by thinking of what recently
comes to mind-- what
most immediately comes to mind.
That's a behavioral
economics finding.
So departures from rationality
are people hate losses.
They dislike losses more than
they like corresponding gains.
We can do that in this room.
Half of you, it's just
courtesy of the organizers,
half of you at the
end of this talk
are going to have to put
$10-- sorry, sorry people--
$10 on this podium.
That's the price of coming.
But I'm not going
to pocket anything,
because the other half
of you, each of you
is going to get one
of the $10 they gave.
I completely made that up.
But if we did, that the utility
in the room would go down.
Because it wouldn't be held
constant, even though the money
held constant,
because losing $10
is more sad-making than getting
out $10 is happy-making.
So that's behavioral stuff.
And that behavioral
stuff, it's just robust.
That's how human beings are.
I gave some examples.
It doesn't matter
what technology
is, the behavioral stuff, that's
either hardwired or just homo
sapiens.
The informational cascade
and network effects
and reputational cascades,
that also shouldn't change
in its nature as
technology changes,
though you're completely
right, that's not behavioral.
That's more standard economics.
That shouldn't change in its
nature, though how it manifests
itself will change.
So you can create an
informational cascade
of the most preposterous
sort in the political domain
on the internet easily,
whereas pre-internet,
that was really hard.
You can create a
reputational cascade
among a group of, let's
say, "Star Wars" lovers
easily on the internet.
So if you say-- I'm a victim
of reputational cascade,
by the way.
I've said that the
prequels are under-rated.
I love them, love
them, love them.
And one of the nation's
leading newspapers
described that judgment on
my part as unforgivable.
That's reputational
pressure, big time.
The internet can create
people who find themselves
into groups of types, niches,
who are often linked tightly.
And that will change.
What I'm thinking is
fantastic in your question
is in 1970s, because the
universe of communications
options was so
much smaller, that
to create an explosive network
effect, as "Star Wars" did,
so it was everywhere,
a lot easier.
On the other hand,
in nominal dollars,
at least, "The Force
Awakens" beat "A New Hope."
it didn't in real dollars, but
that's probably a footnote.
I think "The Force Awakens"
is very, very good,
but "A New Hope" is kind
of world-historically good.
And the fact that "The Force
Awakens" did so incredibly
well, it's good network
effects, cascade effects.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for being here.
My question is that I notice
that one of your explanations
is not just sheer
luck, that there
is something predictable here.
And in the
entertainment industry,
they for a long time have
been trying to figure out
is there this
predictable formula
that we can bet
a blockbuster on.
But the reality is
because subjective taste
is so unpredictable,
they need to put out
a lot of different blockbusters.
And if just one
of those succeed,
it will make up for
all of the failures.
So is "Star Wars" just
simply that one magic bullet?
CASS R. SUNSTEIN: OK.
So as between the predictability
and unpredictability side,
I'm on the latter side.
So the fact that the Arab Spring
occurred, at least when it did,
is something like the
music download study.
That one or another
political candidate
becomes triumphant, a lot
of serendipity and stuff.
So you need the thing to have
a certain level of quality.
That's a necessary
condition for it to do well.
But it's not sufficient.
So I'm there.
The-- what I'm hoping
to-- I can't prove that.
So as a data person, I should
be very tentative here.
But what I'd like to believe,
and therefore believe,
is that not withstanding the
studios, I think explicable--
and I'll say something about
why it's explicable-- pessimism
about "Star Wars" is
completely amazing.
It had to do well.
Too amazing.
Now, the true
unpredictability people,
and I'm part of
that family, do not
like what I'm saying right now.
But what I'm saying right
now is just too amazing.
There are many
things that succeeded
that are great, but were
not too amazing to be great.
They needed something like a
network effect or a cascade
effect.
But if you look at the opening
scenes of "A New Hope," when
there's the big ship, and
it goes on and on and on,
it's like a joke.
And I was there in
the first month,
and I felt transfixed
myself, as if I was
the only person in the theater.
It was me and the ship.
But I'm told by people who
weren't quite that transfixed,
and it was probably
true in my audience,
people stood and cheered.
They couldn't believe it.
They'd never seen
anything like that before.
So that leaves a mystery.
Why did the studio not get it?
And the explanation
for that-- this is also
very tentative-- it was just
so foreign to their models
for explosive success.
It wasn't like "Gone with
the Wind" in any way.
It wasn't like any movie
that had broken out.
It seemed like space fantasy.
Could you think of
a space fantasy that
did great before "Star Wars"?
No.
"Star Trek," on TV.
But that's a different thing.
So then the puzzle-- then
playing with this explanation,
and we don't have a
randomized control trial,
so I mean, tentative,
playing with this explanation
that it was too great to fail.
Then the puzzle is not
why did it do well,
but why did the studio not
know that it would do well?
And then the idea
would be some things
just are not
anticipated to do well,
even though they're
astonishingly good,
because they're so unfamiliar.
Who would have-- and
maybe that's what happened
with "Harry Potter," too.
Who would have thought that
those things, even if they're
great, would become every
childhood's favorite reading
experience?
AUDIENCE: So I feel
like you're sort
of touching on
something that jibes
with my recollection
of seeing "A New
Hope" for the first
time, which is that--
but you didn't touch on
this in your sort of laid
out explanations,
possible explanations why
this is doing good.
To me, the movie felt fresh.
It felt new.
It felt like something
I'd never seen before,
like from the
opening credits that
roll by in this
three-dimensional view of space
all the way down to all the
special effects and so forth.
Which, of course, now
feel kind of dated.
But, I mean, don't you
think that had something
to do with popular
success in the same way
that if you look at popular--
if you look at the Beatles that
came out, right, even
though it was in some sense
recycling things that had gone
on before, as was "Star Trek,"
right?
Because they were recycling
sword play and old movie themes
and editing tricks.
But it still had this
freshness quality,
but it felt like something
we'd never seen before.
Of course, like, the
counterpoint to that is now
my kids see "Star Wars"
for the first time,
they still think it's great,
even though it can't possibly
feel fresh.
CASS R. SUNSTEIN: It's
really interesting.
In law, the most fresh and
original and kind of as a law
student joyful of treatises,
if that's not an oxymoron,
is a book on torts by Prosser.
It's outdated now but fantastic.
And it seemed kind of like
the Star Wars of treatises.
And the author Prosser
wrote movingly,
I think, in his
preface, "a pack rat
is at best a collector
and no heroic figure,
and the most that can be said
for him is that he sometimes
chooses well."
Now, the reason I have that
association as you talk
is that having studied
Lucas, he is a genius.
But he's also a pack
rat and a collector.
So I'm trying to square
that with your true point
that the freshness.
He originally wanted to
remake "Flash Gordon,"
didn't have the money
to buy the rights.
Then, he wanted to draw heavily
on a Japanese movie called
"The Hidden Fortress."
And that's very much in "Star
Wars" in the original script.
Of what became "Star
Wars," it kind of
was plagiarism of
"Hidden Fortress."
And all of the elements
you could find.
Even the opening crawl
went back to stuff
that Lucas loved
from a younger age.
So you're clearly right
that it got the freshness.
But I want to think more about
whether that was indispensable
to the success or is that
sufficient for the success.
And it's true, there was
nothing ever like that.
But there are a lot of things
that there was nothing ever
like that people said, oh
my god, that's terrible.
So Lucas did another movie,
"American Graffiti," which
was spectacularly successful.
He did science fictiony
kind of exploration movie.
I just wrote a book
about "Star Wars,"
and I don't remember the
full name of that movie.
I'm not going to guess.
But I tried to watch it.
I'm sure it's my failure
and not the great Lucas'.
But it didn't do well, that
movie, and that was fresh.
AUDIENCE: "THX."
CASS R. SUNSTEIN: Yeah,
that's it, THX-38.
AUDIENCE: 1138.
CASS R. SUNSTEIN:
1138, there we go.
You cheated.
You looked on the internet.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I've seen the movie.
I remember how boring it was.
CASS R. SUNSTEIN: OK,
great, so that attests to
it had to be fresh,
but also electric.
So maybe the awesomeness
of the movie,
I haven't gotten into
enough in these remarks,
and I think that's
clearly right.
So Lawrence Kasdan,
the coauthor, one
of the things he said
about the movie is it,
the Star Wars movies is they
move like a son of a bitch.
And that's part of the
freshness, just this energy.
And Lucas said, to spell
out a little bit what
he loved-- not what he loved,
what he noticed in his movies,
he said what defines
them is they have
a kind of giddy exuberance.
And he said that's very
surprising because I'm not
at all like that as a person.
And I've met him, and he's
a very present and intense
person.
He's not giddy.
AUDIENCE: I definitely
agree with you on the, um,
the second thing is it did
feel electric and it moved,
you know.
And that was the
other, like, going
back to how I felt
about it as a kid,
that was the other thing
that was a [INAUDIBLE].
But like pulling
apart the themes
for me and the
father-son relationship,
doesn't resonate with how
I remember perceiving it.
CASS R. SUNSTEIN: Well,
there's a question
of individual experience.
And then, there's a question
of social aggregates.
So my contention,
which you know is
based on something
like thick description
rather than randomized
controlled trial--
thick description
of the phenomenon
and how it's been
experienced culturally
is that the father-son
theme really gets to people.
And that the twist
on the monomyth,
about the power of agency, is
something people completely
resonate to.
Though it may be for you, it
was the freshness of the images.
And there's no
question that Lucas'
spectacular visual
imagination is
part of the secret sauce
that made this work.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.